[Music]
unprecedented crowds expressing
widespread support for Palestinians in
Gaza from New York and Washington DC and
across the United States more than a
million Americans have been taking part
in protests marches and visuals since
October the
7th this protest in the capital marks
the largest Pro Palestinian mobilization
in US history with many calling on the
government to stop its milit Ary support
for Israel enough is enough it can't go
on and we need the White House we need
Biden to listen because you can hear it
out
here in London a pro Palestinian March
stretched across several streets and
from Paris to Berlin people from
different races and religions denounce
the massacres committed in the GSA strip
I think uh when you see the diversity of
the people here they don't have to be
Arab they don't have to be Muslim they
me personally I'm not Muslim I'm
Christian Palestinian I think the
message is like the the general
sentiment and the of of the population
is that like something has to be
done in the Philippines and other
countries across Asia calls to free
Palestine resonated among thousands of
demonstrators and despite the distance
for many in Latin America the
Palestinian cause feels close to
home this cannot be called a war it's a
gen side and that's why the protests
will continue wege you with genocide the
scars of a paride in South Africa have
led both the government and protesters
to condemn inequality among Israel's
minorities while also pointing to
injustices faced by Palestinians in
occupied territories we marched against
apartate in South Africa and there's no
reason why we will not stand up for
apartate
against for Generations communities
across the Middle East have called for
an end to the occup ation and the force
displacement of Palestinians and Yemen
and The Wider region those cries are
growing
louder our first and main cause is to
support Palestinians and we will not
give
up and while in Gaza civilians say they
feel their plight is ignored millions of
people around the world want to make
sure they know their cries are being
heard Kia lope Al jaaz
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer